[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit de la vie des acteurs économiques
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes à l'auberge manet à
montigny-le-bretonneux hôtels et
restaurants les de confinement entraîné
de nombreuses difficultés pour cet
établissement
nous reviendrons sur les conséquences de
la crise sanitaire
mais en attendant retrouvez tout de
suite le sommaire de ce huitième numéro
du sky écho dans le cadre du plan france
paulhan le gouvernement propose le
dispositif un jeune une solution
objectif faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes avec une
perte de neuf cents mille euros sur son
chiffre d'affaires pour 2020 looberghe
human et tente de résister en proposant
de la vente à emporter découverte aussi
de l'adaptation du travail du chef
cuisinier
enfin retour sur l'année 2020 de nicolas
halloween
le chef pâtissier a subi le confinement
en fermant sa boutique caramel mais il a
rebondi rapidement en créant l'atelier
gâteau c'est un dispositif
gouvernemental du plan france relance
son nom un jeune une solution objectif
faciliter l'insertion des jeunes malgré
la crise sanitaire ce plan a été lancé
le 23 juillet 2020 et renforcées par une
plateforme sur internet le 19 novembre
regardez ce décryptage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les secteurs de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration subissent de plein fouet la
crise sanitaire
ici à l'auberge du manet le chiffre
d'affaires atteignait l'année dernière
un million neuf cent mille euros pour
l'année 2020
il devrait tout juste dépasser un
million cent mille euros
on fait le point tout de suite avec la
directrice de l'établissement
nous avons rejoint la dirigeante de
l'auberge du magny isabelle bianchi
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue dans la
maison
merci nous accueillir justement et alors
on va parler de la crise sanitaire votre
établissement est fermé et un premier
confinement on est confiné
quelle est la situation de votre
établissement ba aujourd'hui sur l'année
2020 la situation est telle qu'on a
perdu neuf cent vingt mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires
hier notre chiffre d'affaires journalier
était de 324 euros et que et bien
évidemment on subit de plein fouet cette
crise sanitaire et qu'on essaie de
chercher par tous les moyens de résister
en fait alors vous réalisez quand même
du chiffre d'affaires parce que vous
avez quand même un hôtel et vous êtes
aussi adapté par rapport à aux côtés
restauration tout à fait sûr le premier
confinement on a eu un petit peu de mal
à réagir parce qu'on était vraiment pas
du tout habitués à ce genre d'événement
sur le 2ème confinement je me suis posé
vraiment la question parce que j'avais
besoin de rester en contact avec mes
clients et donc on s'est mis à faire la
vente à emporter et à communiquer
énormément sur ce sur ce projet
néanmoins ça reste bien bien en dessous
de ce qui peut être fait
mais ça nous permet de rester vivant et
d'être toujours là en tout cas si on
fait appel en ce qui concerne l'hôtel on
est sur une occupation de trois ou
quatre chambres par jour quelquefois 6
mais encore une fois on veut être là on
veut exister être vivant par rapport à
nos clients habituellement vous recevez
quel type de clientèle est aujourd'hui
justement qui sont les clients les
clients ce sont des images aux rides
errements des français puisque les gens
voyagent plus normal entre avec beaucoup
de d'allemand d'anglais d'italien
espagnol avec ses crises bien sûr on n'a
plus personne mais encore une fois
s'adapter on est là on leur sert des
plateaux repas ont fait des petits
déjeuner en chambre
on fait des runes service et on s'adapte
fête de la gastronomie alors ça doit
être
il ya eu quand même une adaptation je
suppose alors il ya eu une adaptation
mais on s'est très vite on a très vite
réagi et très vite on se dit voilà c'est
ce qu'il faut faire parce que encore une
fois ce n'est pas une question d'argent
c'est juste pour dire aux clients
écoutez si vous voulez dire nous voir si
vous voulez vous faire plaisir en
goûtant d'autres là on est là et on est
prêt à vous servir
et puis des spéciales faites des menus
spécial fait fiscalement sur le menu de
noël le jour de l'an et à ma grande
surprise on a déjà vendu beaucoup
beaucoup là pour le coup beaucoup de
repas de noël et le jour de l'an et bien
justement on va aller voir votre chef
cuisinier pour savoir comment il adapte
son travail par rapport à la vente à
emporter
[Musique]
nous sommes avec le chef armindo machado
de l'auberge manet bonjour bonjour
alors comment vous êtes adapter à cette
situation comment vous travaillez au
quotidien maintenant et bien en ce
moment en raison de la fermeture en fait
de la vente à emporter et donc on s'est
adapté on a adapté les équipes et au fur
à mesure qu'on a des commandes est bien
on vient les faire au jour le jour fête
de la gastronomie
comment on dresse finalement parce que
la cuisine pour pas trop changé mais le
dressage commandes restent dans une
barquette va écouter c'est vrai que
c'est un peu nouveau pour nous ça mais
finalement on
on réussit à faire la même qualité
mais évidemment au niveau présentation
faut avoir un peu plus d'imagination
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve sur la carte à
la fois pour maintenant il ya les fêtes
aussi terre prochain oui alors en ce
moment nous avons un
ce qu'on appelle un plateau convent midi
et soir à 20 euros sur commande et nous
avons mis en place un menu de fête que
nous avions déjà préparé au cas où nous
serions ouverts et on a décidé de le
vendre à emporter
voilà c'est un menu
un peu plus festif que ce qu'il y a
habituellement avec du chapon des
langoustines du tourteau une bûche
voilà ce qu'est ce moment je suis au
quotidien du coup qui se retrouvent dans
ce menu au quotidien dans les menus que
nous avons actuellement en vente sur le
site on retrouve du saumon une escalope
de saumon avec des tagliatelles de
légumes aux olives
on retrouve une
une suprême de volaille avec une
ratatouille froide ça reste toujours un
peu dans le thème un peu du sud ici un
peu provençal et on retrouve également
des choses un peu plus élaboré on
retrouve le une terrine de foie gras à
la mandarine
on peut aussi avoir un risotto gambas
différents produits que nos clients ont
l'habitude de voir chez nous et je vois
une bûche 1 et la bûche de noël voilà
alors là notre pâtissier nous a préparés
pour tout le mois une petite bûche est
praliné noisette convoi non seulement
pour le menu festif mais aussi pour les
gens qui ont envie de se faire plaisir
même avant noël avec ce dessert merci
armindo machado le chef cuisinier de
l'auberge du manet à
montigny-le-bretonneux
on reste dans le domaine culinaire avec
le chef pâtissier guyancourt toi nicolas
halloween on le connaît pour sa boutique
caramel avec un cas il a ouvert en début
d'année une boutique atelier appelé
gâteau à guyancourt
il poursuit son aventure à travers ces
confiseries ses chocolats et pâtisseries
ou encore ses bûches de noël ont fait le
point sur l'évolution de son activité
dans la séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle nicholas lewin
j'ai 35 ans et je suis dirigeant de
l'atelier gâteau abus en quoi depuis
cette année bientôt c'est un bébé du
confinement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était à la tête d'une société d'une
pâtisserie parisienne qui s'appelait
caramel on a fermé malheureusement
pendant confinement au mois de mars
l'activité avec caramel à démarrer en
2015 l'atelier de fabrication était basé
à gland corps depuis 2015 et la boutique
était à paris
on a eu des grèves on a eu les gilet
jaune on a terminé avec le confinement
quand on a énormément souffert de ça et
donc on a dû malheureusement fermé la
boutique ou moins de mars
et c'est pour ça que la mutation entre
caramel et à tous les gâteaux s'est
opéré pendant cette période
au départ c'était vraiment de pouvoir
apporter aux gens qui étaient confinées
à la maison des gâteaux donc on faisait
uniquement de la livraison
aujourd'hui on est ouvert du mercredi au
dimanche on continue d'assurer les
livraisons
samedi le dimanche et en fait on s'est
fait une clientèle grâce et à partir du
confinement
on a juste répondu à une demande est en
fait cette demande est dorénavant
croissante et les clients vous allez le
voir font la queue maintenant de longues
minutes pour venir chercher leur
commande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le concept d'atelier gâteau c'est très
simple cd gâteau à partager qui change
chaque semaine tous les vendredi samedi
dimanche ont créé deux nouveaux gâteaux
le reste de la semaine c'est une
pâtisserie n'était pas une pâtisserie
conventionnelle par contre vous allez
retrouver des macarons
vous allez retrouver des chocolats et
pas mal de spécialités d'exception des
viennoiseries tous les jours
[Musique]
énorme actu pour nous parce qu'on a la
chance de pouvoir participer au salon du
chocolat du japon c'est le seul salon du
chocolat qui aura lieu cette année pour
ça on a créé des spécialités c'est un
petit biscuit à la noisette avec un peu
de fleur de sel un caramel aux gens du
jas donc le genre du ja c'est quoi c'est
du chocolat avec de la pure pâte de
noisette des noisettes grillées à coeur
en éclats et le tout enrobé d'un
chocolat au lait on est sur une bourde
en lisent et ça je suis sûr que japon ça
va faire un malheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi l'émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet et sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tou tv 78
[Musique]